the biden administration is expanding
efforts to reunite families
separated under the trump
administration's immigration policies
despite progress hundreds of migrant
children still
remain separated from their parents the
biden administration now says it will
allow those families to get back
together
in this country and then look for legal
ways for them to stay
maria villarreal spoke to a father in
ohio who did get his daughter back in
2018
after a very harrowing ordeal
daniel paz and his daughter angie have
been living in ohio
nearly three years after crossing the
border
is this what you expected when you
decided to come to america
no because it's you know like
i thought like when they hear my problem
and they see that was a real problem and
i was coming with my daughter they're
gonna help me
did you know that there was a
possibility you would be separated from
your
family from your children no
in 2018 they fled honduras fearing for
their lives
but as soon as they arrived in texas
they were detained
and heard rumors of being separated i
took a pen to
try to prepare my daughter if that
happened
and i started to write the phone number
of my father
in all her body and the phone number of
my
wife you know her body so if somebody
take her and your daughter is seven
years old
how are you explaining this to her
she cried she was afraid she was shaking
but i explained her i tell her look
don't worry
i'm gonna look for you i'm gonna find
you
and you're gonna be good don't worry
their separation took place during the
trump administration's
zero tolerance policy overall it's
estimated that more than 5
thousand children were separated from
their parents
paz and his daughter were reunited after
less than two months
that's because when a court order forced
the government to bring families back
together
paz was still detained in the u.s so the
government had a record of where he and
his daughter were
unlike hundreds of others he hadn't yet
been deported
but the parents of 506 children still
can't be found and only about one-third
of those parents
are thought to be living right here in
the u.s paz says there is another factor
complicating reunifications now
he says many parents feel their children
are better off in the u.s
without them if i go back to my country
i lose my life i lose the life
of my kids they're gonna disappear us
you're saying that these parents are so
scared
that that they would much rather be
separated i'll stay in my home country
and the kids stay in the u.s they keep
running for their lives in the countries
they keep running always for their lives
trying to be safe
paz believes he is one of the lucky ones
but he still
worries about the long-term effects on
his family
when they take my daughter from me they
give me another
person back they didn't give me back my
daughter
angeline was completely different
to give you some context this morning on
why so many of these families come here
to the u.s we took a
took a look at a study from doctors
without borders from 2018 that spoke
with migrants
from honduras el salvador and guatemala
two-thirds of the people they spoke with
said they had experienced either
kidnapping murder or the disappearance
of a relative
in those countries highlighting
obviously
how dire the situation is to them
gail maria thank you so much and dire is
the word guys we went to the border at
the time and the majority of the people
there
came because they were afraid and
they're looking for better lives nobody
in this room
would accept being separated from their
children no these young kids who were
separated from their children and we
the united states government did that
every time i think about that it makes
my blood boil don't make such a
dangerous journey no
unless what you're leaving is even yes
yeah were there some bad actors in the
crowd
probably but that was certainly not the
majority
certainly not the majority what i'm
really struck by and maria's report is
that father says the daughter he got
back is not the same how could they be
anthony no i know that's heartbreaking
heartbreaking is right you did that